I'm actually in a grave right now as you
can see finalized you know Allah the
Creator smoked that every soul will
taste death and the prophet saw some had
told us to think often about the
destroyer of pleasures because we get
caught up living life some of us are
living a really good life acquiring
wealth having families children and
doing many good things but then there's
others that are just the lighting in
their passions whims and desires and
forgetting to give thanks forgetting to
prepare for this reality look in this
box that we're going to actually be in
it's a uh there's hope there for the
person who's prepared for this day who's
invested in the hereafter who has tried
to live a good life a life that is upon
pleasing the Almighty the one who has
given us life will give us death if the
one who were gonna return back to we
lived upon the way that he told us to
live and we were in a constant state of
of taqwa of god-consciousness reminding
ourselves of this day not being heedless
of it and then it comes and we're asleep
which is going through life like zombies
fitting in following our desires and the
signs come to us you might be watching
this and it's a sign to reflect and
that's it that's something we can all
agree upon that death it will come to us
all so we can either be asleep to it or
we can be awake and then trying to
figure out what am i created for what's
the purpose of my life is it to acquire
houses mansions money go through all the
drama and stress and then I die and then
what I just fall asleep I turn to dust
no this is just the transition point
from here we move on to the Hereafter
the day of judgement and then as the
deciding factor Paradise or the Hellfire
this is what Jesus Moses Abraham the
last the final messenger probe Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him all of
the messengers that the Almighty sent
that Allah sent they all want people
they call people to worship the Creator
not the creation to do good deeds and to
prepare for a day of reckoning of
bringing oneself to account now and
that's the test of life this is a great
reminder for myself so on Allah first
and foremost and this is where it
started for me at a turning point was
really contemplating and thinking about
this moment there we're gonna be in this
box right here
Six Feet Under
you can't take none of it with you
that's it we know that three things
follow us to the great problem home a
peace and blessings be upon him and told
us that your family will follow you to
the grave your wealth and your deeds the
two will stay behind but your deeds will
come with you so let's really live
purpose seek our purpose that you
haven't found it and the best way to do
that is with a sincere heart asking the
one who created the heart the one who
created you the one who created me the
universe and everything in it to guide
us and the people who have found that
guidance to live upon it no matter what
you've done in the past now is the time
to get it right to make Toba to repent
isohunt a law to be prepared this is I
mean this is that that moment that it's
gonna come to us so be awake now
otherwise when the reality kicks and
when it happens and you're been asleep
it's gonna be of no benefit please be
with you Sonic
able to